is nickelodeon paramount i think it's
paramount right right in paramount
the [ __ ] thing is there's so many
streaming services now that it's just
impossible to keep up on where
everything is at well it's because like
since disney plop uh disney plus started
popping off it's like every other
programming now it's just like oh we can
do that as well it's not just that it's
people are realizing oh people don't use
netflix anymore or not as many people
use netflix anymore yeah and yeah disney
plus apps has been like absolutely
killing it in terms of sales and numbers
which makes me yeah it does it does
disney's gonna own everything it does
make me sick it doesn't make me sad yeah
we're gonna own literally everything
yeah we're gonna we're all gonna be i
mean we've kind of get ready for the
national currency of uh japan
disney coins yeah
when's the disney cryptocurrency coming
out that's probably going to be a more
stable coin than the yen no they won't
settle for crypto they'll have their own
fiat currency they'll take over like
venezuela or something and they'll be
like we should buy it let's buy
venezuela it's like what are you using
venezuela mickey coin yeah we're making
uh yeah mickey coin and then that's it
i'm telling you she's gonna own
everything yeah why like it's scary they
own so much stuff yeah yeah yeah but
like we've gone back we've gone back to
the point now where we it's basically
cable tv again where you you pay for so
many streams
yeah and you don't know where every
stream
you want to watch the show and like i
want to watch x show and i'm like where
where do i watch it yeah which channel
which which channel is on you know at
least with cable you kind of got
everything
now you can't get everything yeah now
i'm like oh [ __ ] i kind of miss having
the bundle where you got everything in
one evening now it's like an individual
cable for each i just like
i do not
i just don't
it's gone back now where i'm like i just
don't want to pay for all these
streaming services like i have amazon
prime just because i want amazon prime
not not because i want to watch [ __ ] i
don't i i i'd rather like pull my eyes
out than use the amazon prime video
service it's awful it's so bad yeah and
then apple tv [ __ ] off absolutely no i'm
not one i don't even own anything apple
yeah so even if there's a show i want to
watch on apple tv like severance how how
do i watch it i will pay money to watch
it but i'm not buying an apple thing and
i'm not buying an apple tv so like now i
can't watch it all right you want to
watch something else it's on paramount i
don't even know paramount had something
yeah and then cnn had their own thing a
while back they colossally failed yeah
yeah they did it was awful yeah hulu
who
poop well who else yeah in america
that's it's fine but like outside of
america sucks and then like what else is
there there's a disney plus i don't care
about disney i don't want to watch
disney stuff yeah you're not missing if
you don't care about like star wars or
marvel there's literally like no then
maybe i want to watch one tv show one
time yeah exactly oh [ __ ] me exactly
now though
the thing is i i agree we have actually
not just devolved
it's worse now because at least with
cable packages you could cancel all of
them at once you could count they came
with a bundle so you could cancel the
bundle that you wanted right yeah now
you you don't even know like how to
cancel mostly services right that's what
i [ __ ] hate it's easier to cancel
cable services than it is to cast your
[ __ ] subscription for one of these
services what is an absolute [ __ ]
night now there's subscription services
that will manage your subscription
services that's how out of control
subscription service has gotten
you actually serious yeah yeah there's
like apps where you put in all your
stuff and you can manage them and it'll
tell you when it's news and stuff yeah
what if i want to unsubscribe from that
that's how bad like this has got like
people just like i actually i genuinely
believe it's way harder to like manage
your money now than ever before because
like people are just paying for [ __ ]
that they don't realize and you just
keep forgetting until you get the money
taken out like [ __ ] yeah yo dog i heard
you got subscription services
well did you okay did you hear the thing
about the bmw cars the what no so
okay you're oh my god have you heard of
this there's a bmw car right that you
could buy
and when you bought the car to to have
the heating seat heating and the seats
enabled you to pay subscription service
are you serious yeah yeah you know i
heard about this what
i i'm i'm genuinely serious like look it
up you'll see they they were selling a
car where if you wanted to have the
seats be heated it's it's already in the
car yeah like yeah just to enable it you
to pay month monthly yeah how how much
do you have to pay it was something it
was
a what 18 a month 18 dollars a month 18
dollars a month for heated
uh for a seats or 300 for three years
three hundred dollars for three what
did you not hear about what
yeah i was like that one actually like i
i never had a visceral reaction when i
heard that i was like you have no no at
one point no point isn't too far like we
are like
just like would you like to open your
window we are living the dystopian
nightmare your black mirror was [ __ ]
right man
well it's because they've taken like the
ryanair approach to cars yeah i think
their argument was that the car is
cheaper for it yeah we're selling it
cheaper but if you want you can pay what
would be the normal price
but you can turn it on but i'm like this
is stupid because surely after x amount
of years you'll have made a profit on
the fact that i was buying heated seats
i just i just i hate it so much i hate
the idea of paying a subscription for oh
god it's just so dirty like i wouldn't i
wouldn't mind like i wouldn't mind
subscription so much if it was just as
easy to like sign off like to just exit
the subscription as it was to enter the
subscription but unfortunately [ __ ]
designs you know you wanna you wanna you
wanna cancel the subscription okay let's
uh let's hide this webpage
[ __ ] like
five clicks in the small in the small
prints and then you have to [ __ ] even
like the the ones where you see how
these ux designers should be slapped the
ones where you have to email the service
in order to cancel your subscription
[ __ ] you yeah [ __ ] you okay
actually actually [ __ ] you if
you know i can kind of understand if
there's a button hidden away in the user
settings somewhere okay i can kind of
understand but if you have to go out
your way to message the service to
cancel the [ __ ] subscription that is
that's [ __ ] up okay yeah but then you
just do the you cancel your card huh you
just
just just cancel your card
well i know a lot of people use that
that's
like a
it's like i could turn off my tv with
the remote or i could just pull the
[ __ ] thing out of the wall
like you on on i don't know about your
app on one of my uh apps it allows me to
cancel descriptions from my bank oh
really so i can like tell it to stop and
it'll just
[ __ ] pull my card out okay um but
there's also i know this is i thought
you meant just like [ __ ] setting your
card
i know there's a service i i don't use
it i'm too lazy yeah there's a service
where you can uh put your your card into
this thing and every time you want to
sign up through subscription it'll make
a new card within the this app yeah and
is that also a subscription service i
think shows right
but at least then you can like if you
want to give an app your credit card
yeah you can give it a card that you can
just turn off anytime so if you want to
like just hard be like nah [ __ ] you yeah
um i don't know though i've never tried
it i i don't know how good it is i'm
just talking out of
my ass
and i found it online
i don't know how good they are it might
also be again like literally anything
anything is like uh like i bought um
i bought those uh tile trackers right
it's amazing right great but but one one
caveat and i didn't know this when i was
buying it
there's like you don't actually get to
do everything with this tracker
it'll only tell you where it is now and
it has a function where it's like do you
want to see where it was the last 30
days so you click oh view last 30 days
oh pay three dollars a month to see
where it was a few days are you serious
yeah dead dead serious let me show you
and then like uh it's just a bunch of
other random [ __ ] and where it like
debates you yeah into like um
so if i go oh like smart alerts yeah
look so if i go smart alerts
boom it's like get more go premium 30 30
pounds a year yeah and it's like
i
i already paid a lot of money for these
stupid things so like why
why are you charging me a lot of money i
don't know i don't get it to me it's
like do you hate me
what did i do
that makes you hate me this much
yeah [ __ ] we we're living we are
literally like living the dystopian
nightmare we're gonna be like cyberpunk
2017 micro transactions for every
necessity when is
when when are when is like gacha gonna
be
more popularized in the gaming industry
i think it's only a matter of time
unfortunately i mean it's i would argue
it's already pretty [ __ ] popular what
do you mean this is [ __ ] rampant
yeah but i remember when gacha games was
just like oh that those are like the
weeb games right yeah and then everyone
else was complaining about micro
transaction but because of gentian
impact you know unfortunately i'm also a
gentian player so i've like contributed
to the evil unfortunately well i've been
zero days yeah
it's just like normalized now
unfortunately yeah i think it's got to
the point where people even in like
other mainstream games i think so i
think so people don't bat an eye now
about dropping 100 bucks on randomized
[ __ ] boxes
and
are you talking about gotcha or loot
boxes both okay loot boxes are catching
yeah that's the same thing
that's what i meant they just don't
specifically say gotcha right they they
leave that term analogy for the weeb
games but like everything else just like
yeah it just says another [ __ ]
synonym to that word and just pretends
that it's not gacha yeah right it's like
no it's [ __ ] gotcha yeah
i think gotcha is hilarious when it's
taking money from rich people but when
people are like broken doing it i'm like
oh yeah this is sad